bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de bernard
henri lévy
bernard henri lévy est un philosophe
français né en 1948 on peut le
considérer comme le plus grand
philosophe français depuis descartes des
cartes avec qui bhl a d'ailleurs un
point commun qui est d'être expert dans
plusieurs domaines
des cartes étaient à la fois philosophe
mathématicien physicien et bien de la
même façon bernard henri lévy n'est pas
seulement un philosophe c'est également
un riche homme d'affaires héritier de
l'entreprise de son père
spécialisée dans l'exploitation du bois
précieux africain une entreprise qui
sera vendue en 1997 pour la modique
somme de 750 millions de francs
et cette fortune durement acquise
permettra à bernard henri lévy décrire
ses plus grandes oeuvres dans les hôtels
du monde entier
outre ses compétences dans le monde des
affaires on sait par son épouse arielle
dombasle que comme beaucoup de grands
hommes de science avant lui bernard
henri lévy s'intéresse aussi
particulièrement à la chimie dans
laquelle il semble qu'il aurait trouvé
une certaine source de motivation
bien que son humilité le pousse à rester
discret sur ce sujet
on signalera enfin ses talents de
cinéaste
il est le réalisateur du film le jour et
la nuit un film que certains critiques
de mauvais goût ont qualifiée à l'époque
de suicide artistique
probablement par manque de subtilité ou
parce qu'ils n'ont pas lu levinas
alors si on devait humez l'oeuvre
philosophique de bhl pour peu qu'on
parvienne à la pénétrer on pourrait dire
que les deux grands axes de sa pensée
sont d'une part l'engagement aux côtés
des opprimés et d'autre part la lutte
contre toutes les formes de fascisme et
de populisme
vaste programme mais un programme qui
sera sans doute mieux compris si on
tient compte du fait que bernard henri
lévy est né au 1 rue karl marx
karl marx défense des opprimés la
corrélation est trop évidente pour ne
pas être remarqué
et il est aussi probable qu en tant
qu'héritier d'une entreprise
d'exploitation de bois africain bernard
henri lévy et était très tôt
sensibiliser à la problématique des
inégalités sociales
l'avantagent des inégalités sociales est
temps qu'on peut les constatée aussi
bien quand on les subit que quand on en
bénéficie
pour entrer dans la pensée de bernard
henri lévy on va partir de son ouvrage
le plus connu un ouvrage de référence
publié en 1981 qui s'intitule
l'idéologie française et à propos duquel
le philosophe raymond aron sans doute un
peu aigri et jaloux du jeune philosophe
dira je cite qu'il viole toutes les
règles de l'interprétation honnête et de
la méthode historique
alors raymond aron ne sera ni le premier
ni le dernier à critiquer le travail de
bernard henri lévy prouvant par là que
bhl a raison lorsqu'il écrit dans
l'idéologie française que la france
constitue le laboratoire conceptuelle du
fascisme européen
car le fait que raymond aron se soit
permis de critiquer publiquement cet
ouvrage et son auteur devrait suffire à
prouver que la france est bel et bien la
matrice idéologique du fascisme
on remarquera d'ailleurs que le premier
mot de l'idéologie française et vichy si
on met de côté l'avant propos qui lui
commence par jeu et que le dernier mot
de l'épi log et racisme
le livre aurait d'ailleurs pu se limiter
à ces trois mots jeux vichy et racisme
car ils portent en eux la quintessence
de l'engagement philosophique de bhl
alors il faut préciser que dans l'oeuvre
de bhl l'histoire des idées politiques
la sociologie ou encore l'économie
occupe une place relativement réduite
d'ailleurs dans une tribune publiée en
2011 bernard henri lévy écrira que je
cite l'économie n'existe pas et que je
cite à nouveau l'économie
c'est comme l'intendance elle suit
et on peut qu'être d'accord avec ça
il est vrai que l'économie n'a pas
vraiment d'influencé dans l'histoire des
nations du monde
il est vrai que les guerres que la
pauvreté que les inégalités n'ont qu'un
très lointain rapport avec l'économie
car ce que bhl a bien compris c'est que
des disciplines comme l'économie ou
comme la sociologie ou l'anthropologie
empêche de voir que la réalité est
beaucoup plus simple à comprendre
à ça art le fait qu'il y à des méchants
c'est ça l'épicentre conceptuelle du
système théorique de bhl
les méchants
alors les méchants peuvent prendre
plusieurs formes
ils peuvent porter plusieurs noms
ce seront par exemple les fascistes ou
les crypto fasciste
ce seront les populistes les
nationalistes les antisémites ou les
anti américain
oui parce que pour bernard henri lévy je
cite
l'antiaméricanisme est une métaphore de
l'antisémitisme
une métaphore de l'antisémitisme
notez la perspicacité conceptuel d'une
telle dénomination
l'antisémitisme par métaphore
le crime par métaphore
saint thomas d'aquin lui-même n'y aurais
pas pensé
donc ce que bernard henri lévy a bien
compris c'est que dès lors qu'on se
penche sur un phénomène et a fortiori
sur un phénomène politique toute
tentative d'en faire la généalogie
historiques ou d'en faire l'analyse
économique représente déjà un premier
pas dans la complicité
car l'analyse n'est ce pas la tentative
de comprendre ce qui ne doit pas être
compris
l'analyse n'est ce pas la règle sion de
l'affect
et la réduction de l'affect n'est ce pas
le terreau du totalitarisme
c'est en tout cas l'hypothèse que
soutiendra bhl dans son livre la
barbarie à visage humain paru en 1977
dans lequel il écrit je cite chacun sait
aujourd'hui que le rationalisme a été un
des trous d'aiguilhe par quoi s'est
faufilé la tentative totalitaire le
fascisme n'est pas issu de
l'obscurantisme
mais de la lumière
fin de citation
tout est dit
et à ce qu'ils diront que bernard henri
lévy critique le rationalisme tout en se
réclamant de la philosophie des lumières
et ils verront ce que des esprits
malveillants appellerons une incohérence
entendons-nous bien
il ne s'agit pas d'une incohérence
il s'agit d'une distinction
d'une distinction absolument crucial
pour qui veut comprendre les fondements
de la pensée bhl yens
la distinction entre le bon rationalisme
et le mauvais rationalisme
le bon rationalisme c'est le
rationalisme de la liberté et du progrès
c'est le rationalisme de voltaire et de
bernard kouchner
c'est le rationalisme sur la base duquel
s'établit ce qu'on appelle le droit
d'ingérence
qui pourra à l'occasion de venir devoir
pour ceux qui ne seraient pas familiers
avec ce concept le droit d'ingérence ça
désigne dans le droit international la
possibilité pour un état d'intervenir
militairement dans un autre si ce
dernier enfreint les droits de l'homme
et la définition juridique de ce concept
prévoit que l'ingérence est motivée par
une obligation morale
l'obligation morale de faire régner les
droits de l'homme y compris par le
recours aux armes
ça c'est le bon rationalisme
rationalisme de la liberté qui doit
s'imposer
il est vrai que dans les faits ce sont
par définition les états militairement
puissant qui ont la possibilité
d'intervenir dans les autres
et qu historiquement on a rarement vu un
pays du tiers-monde s'ingérer dans les
affaires politiques d'une grande
puissance occidentale
mais après tout on n'a jamais vu non
plus qu'un enfant fasse la leçon à ses
parents
pour bhl il est normal que les pays les
plus développés indique aux pays qui le
sont moins la voie du progrès
quoi de plus humaniste
alors évidemment certains diront que
l'ingérence occidentale a surtout permis
d'installer le chaos dans les pays
colonisés pardon dans les pays libéré
l'irak la libye la syrie pour ne citer
que ces quelques exemples
mais enfin on le fait l'aide sans casser
des oeufs
c'est ce qui fait que lorsque ce
reproche lui adresser à bhl se
reprochent de se dire du côté des droits
de l'homme tout en validant des
opérations militaires ayant occasionné
plusieurs milliers de morts dont des
civils
bhl répondra que c'est ça être un
démocrate conséquent
un démocrate conséquent ce n'est pas
quelqu'un qui respecte le droit des
peuples à l'autodétermination
et ce même si cette autodétermination ne
nous plaît pas ou n'arrange pas nos
affaires commerciales
un démocrate conséquent c'est un
démocrate qui souhaite que le monde
entier deviennent démocrate
parce que les démocrates ce sont les
gentils
et que les non démocrates ce sont des
méchants
c'est pourtant ce comprendre
un démocrate conséquent à partisans des
droits de l'homme conséquent c'est un
partisan des droits de l'homme qui
n'hésitent pas à franchir la barrière de
l'autodétermination des peuples pour
imposer ce qu'il estime être la clé de
voûte du bonheur universel
et c'est en cela que bernard henri lévy
a parfaitement raison de se qualifier
lui-même d'homme de gauche
puisqu'il s'inscrit finalement dans la
droite ligne de l'idéal formulée par
jules ferry devant l'assemblée nationale
en 1885
lorsqu ils proclamaient les
civilisations supérieur ont le droit et
même le devoir d'éduquer les
civilisations inférieur
et pour ceux qui estimeraient que ses
propos seraient simplement les propos
d'un homme du 19e siècle et qu'au 19e
siècle tous les européens penser ainsi
soyons clairs ce n'est pas le cas
et c'est d'ailleurs tout le sens de la
réponse de georges clemenceau à
jules-ferry clemenceau qui dira je cite
je ne comprends pas que nous n'ayons pas
été unanime ici à nous lever d'un seul
bond pour protester violemment contre
vos paroles non il n'y a pas de droits
des nations dites supérieures contre les
nations inférieur la conquête que vous
préconisez c'est l'abus pure et simple
de la force que donne la civilisation
scientifique sur les civilisations
rudimentaire pour s'approprier l'homme
le torturer en extraire toute la force
qui est en lui au profit du prétendu
civilisateur ce n'est pas le droit sans
et la négation
alors probablement que si clemenceau
avait vécu à notre époque
il se serait fait le défenseur des
dictature de saddam hussein de muamar
kadhafi ou de bachar al assad
fort heureusement ce sont les
descendants intellectuelle de jules
ferry qui ont survécu
même gardons nous bien de prêter à
bernard henri lévy démotivation
belliciste
bhl n'aime pas la guerre
il a bien dit
il n'aime pas la guerre il fait la
guerre sans l'aimer
une formule empruntée à malraux qui lui
inspira l'écriture d'un livre en 2011
dans lequel il décrit sa participation
active au printemps libyen
s'est surtout fait prendre en photo
devant les tanks de l'armée libyenne
mais bon ça fait quand même de belles
images
la guerre par métaphore
donc là aussi comme il ya le bon
rationalisme et le mauvais rationalisme
il y à la bonne guerre et il y a la
mauvaise guerre
il y a la guerre des gentils pour les
droits de l'homme et il y à la guerre
des méchants pour la dictature
et cette distinction entre le bon et le
mauvais
cette distinction conceptuelle du
solidité intransférable on la retrouve
également chez bhl sur la question du
libéralisme
il y a un bon libéralisme il y a un
mauvais libéralisme
le mauvais libéralisme c'est je cite le
libéralisme qui produit les délits
d'initiés
le bon libéralisme c'est je cite celui
qui les empêchent
sa part est clair
il ya aussi la bonne mondialisation et
la mauvaise mondialisation
la mauvaise mondialisation c'est celle
qui produit les délocalisations le
chômage de masse
l'augmentation des inégalités
et la bonne mondialisation c'est celle
qui produit l'extension des droits de
l'homme et des valeurs démocratiques
la bonne mondialisation c'est ce que
refusent les populistes
toujours enclin à faire obstruction au
progrès pour assouvir leurs pulsions de
haine
et en parlant de populisme
bernard henri lévy a bien compris de
quoi les gilet jaune était l'incarnation
on pourrait croire un peu naïvement que
les gilets jaunes sont un mouvement de
revendication populaire et sociale
ne nous y trompons pas
les gilet jaune
c'est un mouvement qui clame d'abord sa
haine de la démocratie
détestation de la république
et son désir de retour au fascisme
d'ailleurs le st le fait de revêtir un
gilet jaune c'est à dire un uniforme
n'est ce pas une référence directe au
défilé des ministres mussolini
la barre henri lévy lui a bien cerné le
coeur de la revendication des gilet
jaune
le coeur de leurs revendications
ce n'est pas le pouvoir d'achat
ce ne sont pas les taxes sur le
carburant
le coeur de la revendication des gilet
jaune
c'est l'antisémitisme
c'est ça qui motive les mouvements
populaires pas bon les mouvements
populistes
la haine
la haine de l'autre
la n 2 celui qui réussit
la haine de l'argent
bhl combat la haine
et ce qu'a compris bernard henri lévy et
ce en quoi ils surpassent largement la
sagesse d'un socrates c'est que pour
faire triompher une cause
un affect vaut mille concept
une accusation
vomi l'argumentation
pourquoi pensez quand on peut émouvoir
pourquoi analysé quand on peut
criminaliser
pourquoi viser la dette quand on peut
viser les tripes
montagnat erreur de vouloir comprendre
l'autre
il a commis l'erreur de vouloir se
glisser dans la conscience du barbare
parce qu'il considérait que nous sommes
aveugles à notre propre barbarie
mais sensible à la barbarie d'autrui
montaigne disait qu'on pouvait
comprendre les barbares dès lors que
l'on comprend que la barbarie n'est que
le nom donné à ce qu'on ne comprend pas
quel imposteur ce monteil
si bernard henri lévy est bien le
dernière humaniste c'est parce qu'il a
compris qu'on ne prend pas part à
l'histoire et au destin du monde en
cherchant la vérité
on prend part à l'histoire et au destin
du monde en accompagnant la force qui le
gouvernent
on prend part au destin du monde en
dépassant la vérité
en s'asseyant avant elle à la table
et en l'appuyant tu regardes
lorsqu'elle est en face de nous
bhl ou ceux a compris une vérité
fondamentale
à savoir que la raison du truqueur et
généralement la meilleure
prions pour lui
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]